[Music]
in fixed culture ship new submit by I
love Keanu Reeves psychologists suggest
that long-term relationships affect
woman's sexual desire more than men's
like their sexual drive or how sexually
desirable they are to other people like
how interested they are on their partner
like they're just they get bored with
sex Oh so girls get bored quicker than
guys do
girls need engagement bro as a prelude
to size are you bad true am I bored of
you yes yes I could feel it because if a
foul is it follows a [ __ ] grandpa and
I just bent over I still get horny no
matter how old you are your ass and legs
don't age as fast as your face does
until you get that card thank you yeah
that's very sweet
your ass is never a baby you know not as
fast as your face that leap yeah no I
mean I don't think I think like that's
a--that's a very like tough argument to
like as far as like bringing up the sex
conversation like everything's all about
sex with you like so that's what is it
my girl you know me like I don't ever
want to like I try to bring up the idea
of like it's kind of cool like if you
initiate you know I mean like I think
that that's a cool turn-on you know I
mean for the girls to initiate you know
because if I initiate every time then
it's really making me feel like I am the
dog like initiation to mean like I want
to be a bad like fake sleeping in you
pull my my drawers down yeah saying like
cut up sleeping
Oh watch it - yeah like dude like with
your fingers walk down my thigh yeah
give you the sake like stop but there's
a lot of guilt behind that right because
depending on how they were raised like
if they act like it then even if they're
in a committed relationship they might
feel like [ __ ] or whatever so there's
a lot of shame no man I wanna what is it
a lady in the streets and a freaking of
bed I think we all do but sure there's a
battle that they have to deal with
depending on how they were raised
yep that's so true that's true well what
what from if that's the idea if that's
how they were raised what is that like
perspective but we're raised to not be
[ __ ] and like and like tell chicks to
pursue us I think ya know like so like
even if you're even if you're completely
cool with it right and then it is a
chill environment but then she's not
ready for that yet because she's she
never worked through that part of
feeling guilty or bad for wanting it or
saying it openly yeah yeah I grew up
really Catholic and I one wasn't just
used to initiating it cuz it was always
just like the guy like you're saying
something like that's what I was used to
and then just being raised Catholic and
a mex latina female then it was it was
like why are you so horny like you like
I didn't know that like a high sex drive
was normal or that my I might not even
have a high sex drive maybe I just have
a normal sex drive but because of
Catholics raised high sex drive um yeah
yes extra me wanna get all the time then
it's like it's like I just felt guilty
like why do I want it all the time like
I shouldn't be thinking these thoughts
yeah yeah do you think that now
because how many years have you guys
been together okay it's been more than
seven
11 this year yeah I like her your
question is unlike nowhere we said
almost 10 spend 10 for like anyway 10
years you guys been together between the
two of you like you kind of feel like
maybe you've lost the or diminished a
little bit the desire in your sex life I
don't know I don't know for a good
example of that because we kind of
started backwards just because our sex
communication wasn't really there in the
beginning so our so you guys got closer
over time yeah our sex life was kind of
subpar like for both of us and then not
until we're like wait a minute we got
issues what the [ __ ] is going on that
was routed because of just communication
and sex um then for us it's been the
reverse like now it's the best it's ever
been how long did it take to recognize
that there was a problem no and the
voice it out loud with each other um
[ __ ] like nine years and it took that
mom because we were so focused on our
career that like our relationship became
we just went into the back seat because
we just wanted to do YouTube we wanted
to do the gym we want to do so many
things that it was easy for us to just
forget about us it took it took catching
me jackoff in the backyard remember that
sigh do you remember what was that like
reaction were you like was cheating on
me with another like cause he was just
on his phone talking to someone and that
Pat's romo ankle jacket next to the
water heater yeah and he was like no
like he he was like no I'm just peeing
sounds like okay so I had no idea until
like seven years later he's like I was
actually the jacket so kind of like oh
so you didn't know at that moment I
thought he was talking to someone else
so kind of like Catholic schoolgirls
where they have a certain like what was
the word we were using like Buddhist or
Shan Shan yeah I'll girl extremely
Buddhist so sex wasn't nothing that you
would schoolboy you really what is it
called really talked about so so it was
hard for me to express the things that I
wanted to do so sex became like this
very robotic feeling that it only it's
like if she was in the perfect mood I
was in the perfect mood where what
happened yeah but then like like for
guys like your sex drives pretty high
like throughout the day yeah so like she
went to go take a shower and I was like
I'll [ __ ] up I didn't go jack off you
know and I went back yard you know what
this makes jumping in the shower and the
boyish out of her yeah yeah is there
statistics on this or like how to date
well what's this all about
yeah so they're saying here that they
did this study in 2017 study of more
than 11,500 British adults aged 16 to 74
most British people that's what not I
found that quote for women only lack of
interest in sex was higher among those
in a relationship of over one year in
duration and that women living with a
partner were more likely to lack
interest in sex than those in other
relationship categories and they're also
saying that in a 2012 study of 170 men
and women aged 18 to 25 who were in
relationships of up to nine years
similarly found that women's sexual
desire was the same so not really men's
because for women it was significantly
and negatively predicted by relationship
duration after controlling for age
relationship satisfaction and sexual
satisfaction so like so it's like at a
decline women over time in a
relationship use this one example of
this one couple who it's like John and
Jane they're in their 40s and they've
been together for nearly two decades and
they have sex about three times a week
and that's healthy as [ __ ] so that's
what you would think right
for her she might be doing it as routine
isn't happy so like for her it's like
they're saying that the sex that they're
having it's not the sex that she wants
and she says she's confused by it that's
what they said that and demoralized by
it she thinks that there's something
wrong with her and so the therapist is
commenting on that makes sense
because she feels that she should be
enjoying it as well but also doesn't
know maybe what she wants so like
they're having sex frequently they're
having like she's having orgasms like
but for somebody you're sad about I
think it's the emotional thing cause
like it makes all it makes sense because
women need that emotional tie to the sex
stuff right we're guys like oh that
she's fine
I could come in her mm-hmm I mean like
we do have emotional sex as well but
there's not much of a separation from
just physical release to that experience
because there's just a clear different
sexual experience that we have I can do
emotional sex but it always ramps up
into hate [ __ ] always it's just a
curse still an emotion that's true I
never thought okay
that makes sense because it's like if
you need it's so very engaged and I
think you both are participating in that
yeah that's for sure yeah she wants to
be hated oh yeah yeah she likes being
dominated she said she knows she knows
what she wants and you're yeah and
you're getting what you want what do you
what it sounds like to me is like the
guys getting what he's what he wants but
he's not communicating them and changing
and doing different things well so they
also mentioned that she bought lingerie
booked hotel stays and even even wow
adjusted opening up the marriage Wow but
for her so she's getting bored of sex in
general is it a biological thing yes and
so they are saying that they end up
facing has come oast people in sexual
partnerships and facing this conundrum
biologists called habitual habituation
to in Konoha [ __ ]
to a stimulus so over time a a growing
body of research suggests that
heterosexual women are likely to face
this problem earlier in the relationship
than men
interesting yeah I think it has to just
do with like being spontaneous like
Trancas oh there's another thing of like
um rant I actually heard it on countless
ages with podcast of him and his wife
Pete
the love our de talking about um my
random make-out sessions random ones
that's dope you know mean like like you
go you go to you know go to Ralph's to
the grocery store and before you go poor
you doubt the car if I'm come here just
start making out real quick like I love
you tough situations to where that's
like a random like you know oh nice you
don't mean to we're heading out buying
groceries but the whole time you're
thinking about and we just had a nice
little makeout session when we get back
you know yeah yeah you know that that's
one thing and then also be the fire warm
cotton yeah yeah and then also which I
I've actually it's helped me is um
there's a book of the demand of the ways
it was a period man have you heard that
book why do the audio books are that
what I've listened to yeah um is um when
you're having sex to to focus on this is
gonna be super mushy but focus are not
coming too fast we'll see this is all it
helps that because it's one is the
breathing you know me breathe is so you
know breathing in you know when you
breathe out you like you're exhaling and
like exhaling up for so and they said
that's like releasing the energies up
you don't mean in the the spirits type
of thing so spiritual spiritual that's
that's a spiritual part of it but then
also lovemaking supposed to be connected
to the heart yeah so if you're not gonna
dick exactly
so cuz we're when we're having sex of
course we're focused on the dig that's
all weeks this comes a little quick
we're thinking about the penetration
that's what that's what I'm saying we're
feeling the bum-ass we're feeling that
you know me
it goes down so so anyway if you focus
more on that in you and you forget more
connected on the heart whatever then
your mind you're not thinking about it
so you're actually last longer that's it
focus on the heart because you're
thinking like oh man I love her
no no literally literally connecting
with her heart like heartbeat and heart
like this you're thinking about her
heart like two souls to be you're
thinking about her heart you're thinking
about it pumping you know even when
you're like you guys are like you know
missionary style you're connecting like
pressing your chest against her I think
about it a tease I'm thinking about
titties I'm thinking about asses how the
[ __ ] can you think about anything but
[ __ ] but that's what I'm saying no
like okay do you ever focus on try not
to come some people try to like count
backwards some who do thing with that
one better trying to think about other
[ __ ] so they get laugh longer I start
thinking about ugly old old ladies and
then I started seeing ugly old ladies on
the street and thinking man I shouldn't
have done that cuz now I'm getting horny
I'm so available yeah so but when I when
I do have my girl she actually was like
you know yo like I could I don't know
what I could tell the difference of like
the lovemaking you know man I'm like
yeah I mean I was I was trying this
whole different thing of like connecting
connecting more focusing on the heart an
actual heart going to do and it's like
the bodies exhibit yeah cuz it's a
medium you know I mean that's really
what it is you're focusing on the dude
then I'm gonna go to the grocery store
Heidi make that face when you're
thinking of old ladies how dare you know
right I know know thinking about the
heart because I was like then I'm gonna
go to the grocery store and get a heart
and [ __ ] it
yeah I think for me I'm just thinking
like the absolute destruction of that
[ __ ]
but I understand what you're getting at
I just hi it's hard for me to think
about anything else
yeah no that's no that's what I'm saying
like you have a girl yeah I didn't get
my wife oh nice
congratulations burly that's a little
saying I come at it like a [ __ ]
wrecking ball
[Laughter]
[Music]